hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from yesterday's aimchess
u.s rapid preliminary sis jordan
funforest versus a young sister duda and
it's a game that's kind of reminiscent
of the of the
rubinstein immortal game and if you
haven't seen it do check it out i will
also put a link to that in the
description below it will be the first
thing you will see uh but also as duda
is polish i will also include the link
to the polish immortal so do check out
those two videos if you guys already
haven't because the games are quite
quite impressive and as far as the rapid
chest goes this is as good as it gets so
without further ado let's check it out
uh fun forest with the white pieces
opens with d4 uh we have knight to f6 by
duda we have c4 that's not a c4 we have
c for e6 uh knight to f3 and now d5 we
have bishop to g5 and bishop to g7 so
just a uh nice queens gambit declined
with e3 and now h6 asking do you want to
retreat do we want to capture on f6 uh
jordan captures and now bishop captures
an f6 we have knights to c3 and black
castles uh and now usually you want to
develop your pieces here with uh
queen to rook to c1 queen c2 maybe
bishop to d3
but this is a modern chess and in modern
chess we we push the h pawn so here we
have h4
and the duda replies in a very
principled manner your opponent attacks
on the king side you will counter attack
in the center so c5
uh and now g4 preparing to push that g5
and if black makes a
slow move then g5 is definitely coming
but you could maybe play it for example
if knight c6 uh then white plays g5 and
well it's uh it's just a mess so maybe
not going for that so here we have the
immediate c captures on d4 e capture
sunday for and now uh now duda is
considering whether to continue
developing or to start defending on the
king side and this is one such moment
where maybe you you continue developing
but it's it's a rapid game so i guess
anything goes uh if knight's the c6
which was not played in the game uh then
we allow g5 characters characters
captures captures and now after queen
captures we can play queen d3 we
threaten checkmate and then we can
defend not with the g6 because then you
allow ideas like queen h3 but we'll play
f5 and then you don't really care about
queen h3 because you always have king to
f7 but here by playing g6 right away uh
you uh you merely create a weakness in
in your own camp so here uh jordan
attacks with the g5 with h captures h
captures bishop back to g7 and now queen
to d2 uh the strongest idea the the the
idea is queen to f4 to h4 and then at
some point you will be able to reach
that h7 square but it's never uh really
happening because the rook can always
move and you can never touch the h8
square due to the bishop the bishop is
an excellent defending piece here but
maybe you can you know throw a knight to
e5 at some point and then maybe black
will have to give up his bishop so a lot
of attacking opportunities here for
white we have knight to c6 and now we
have queen side castles here if you rush
with queen to f4 um you don't uh you
don't really have a way of
figuring out how to go about this for
example if queen to a5 uh we already
said that this plan is is no good
because the black will just move the
rook and once you deliver checking
effect and there's no continuing the
attack so here uh jordan first starts by
queen castling queen side we have rook
to e8 and now comes rook to h4 again not
interested in this queen to f4 idea even
though it's a it's a fine square for the
queen uh but okay uh rook to h4 now the
rook also
adds more protection to the d4 pawn and
you can maybe develop the bishop play
the other rook to h1 if if you
will want to
double up on the on the h file uh we
have a6 now uh controlling the b5 square
and now comes king to b1 getting the
king away from that op c file that's
about to open up we have d captures and
c for bishop captures and now duda
finally opens up the position with e5
and now what do you do here well there
are a couple of very interesting ideas
one for such is d5 where both players
would just get a nice pass spawn for
example if knight d4 we're going to play
knight captures e captures now white has
a pass deep on black has a pass d pawn
and now even if knight to e4 we can even
capture this captures captures bishop to
f5 we attack the rook here the rook
cannot move and it would be a fine game
for both sides but here we have queen to
c2 by jordan uh going for that queen
captures on g6 as the f pawn is pinned
you will not be able to capture but uh
he uh
uh allows a bishop to f5 and this is
just no fun for white now uh so here we
have knight the e4 uh blocking this and
now e captures on d4
we have kinked the a1 getting the king
away from this nasty diagonal
and now comes d3 by duda you could also
play rook to c8 also a nice idea as the
queen is on the c file but this way
you are preparing knight to b4 so
whatever captures here you're still
going to go knight to b4 and attack both
the queen and the piece and d3 so here
rook captures on d3 and now comes knight
to b4 attacking the queen and the rook
and you can't trade queens here because
if you trade queen knight captures queen
on c2 with check king to b1 we're going
to capture on d8 and after king captures
here we just deliver a check here and
now you're
you either have to pick it up with the
rook or you have to move the king and
then you lose the knight as well so
you're going to be completely busted
here uh so after knights to b4 uh uh
when four
tries a bishop captures on f7 with check
and now what do you play here uh well
the correct thing to do is play king to
f8 maybe as this is rapid chess but
this runs into queen to c5 check and
then as black's queen is still under
attack you can move the queen defend
your knight and it's kind of fine here
if bishop captures an e8 we're gonna
capture on c five knight captures here
knight captures on d3 and if knight
captures on d3 we're going to play rook
captures on d8 and we get this position
where the material is uh
better for white but it's black who's uh
well almost winning here the bishop pair
is completely fully operational
the rook is just a monster here on the e
file and it's going to be very very hard
for white to defend this however in the
game duda played king captures on f7 and
this is a bit different because black
now has to give up the queen we have
queen to c4 with check uh and what do
you play now uh well we have rook to e6
and now duda is offering a full queen
here but uh there are a lot of a lot of
pieces waiting to be captured after that
queen is off the board so rook captures
on d8 it's the only good move for white
we have rook capture 78 now duda is
threatening checkmate here after the
queen blocks of course uh and you have
to defend this and one way to do it is
queen to b3 which you know may or may
not be good the other one is rook to h1
which is not not so good uh so here uh
well you just start gobbling up pieces
with bishop captures on e4 now the
knight cannot move uh and queen captures
on b4 and now if you want to capture the
knight uh well you run into queen to f4
check and now it's going to be a bit of
a problem defending this position it's
queen and rook against two rooks and the
bishop
white should have enough resources to
you know at least get uh some sort of a
perpetual here
so you have to be very careful and here
duda plays the only winning move and
that's rook to d3 now you attack the the
knight twice you're now ready to capture
it so queen to f4 will not be winning uh
anything back after this check is
delivered so rook to e1 white really
without any any good moves uh and now
the ship captures an f3 uh we have queen
to f4 with check king to g8 and now
again uh there there's no good way to
continue this if queen to be a checking
to h7 we can deliver one more check but
bishop to h5 and everything is perfectly
fine for black so after king to g8 we
have queen to c4 but now duda simply
attacks the queen okay
so bishop and sorry of course you can
never capture here because this is
always checkmate i forgot to mention
this but yeah queen to c4 now with a
double attack on the rook but just
bishop to d5 and now queen to c8 check
we have king to h7 uh and uh well just
what do you play here yeah you can never
capture again because just rook to d1
checkmate you have to move the rook
otherwise rook captures anyone will be
checkmate so here rook the b1 is played
and now uh what do you play here well uh
duda starts with rook to e2 and now look
at this this rook attacking here bishop
attacking here bishop attacking here uh
there's nothing white can do but the
move that uh
jordan made allows duda to finish the
game
in the greatest of styles uh he played
queen to c1 and now of course you will
pause the video and try to find this
spectacular move for duda it's actually
a force mate in eight but only the first
move matters so while i give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
well just unstoppable uh idea and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is rook to a3 rook to a3 and he
was in this position on move 32 that
jordan fun forest resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh it's such a such an ugly position for
white the the bishop cannot capture the
the pawn cannot capture the root due to
the bishop here uh you can't move
anything you can't defend the rook
captures here will just be checkmate and
there's there's really nothing you can
do here you can play some silly moves
but other than that there's no stopping
this so just a spectacular idea and uh
well congratulations to to do down this
uh amazing amazing game
uh so like i said if you still haven't
do check out the rubinstein's immortal
it kind of features a similar bishop
pair a similar queen sacrifice so if you
enjoyed this game you will definitely
enjoy this one it's the first link in
the description below and also check out
the polish immortal uh the second link
in the description below uh so once
again i hope you guys enjoyed it i would
like to thank david kimura vladilat mark
thompson annie mccain and emmanuel
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it we're
gonna check out the standings as the
preliminaries are now over uh so uh
sorry about that we're just gonna have
to make it a little bit smaller so these
are the standings uh to the left are the
people who qualified for the main event
and to the right uh well are the people
that did not the winner of the
preliminaries is vladislav
uh with ten and a half points followed
by magnus carlsen with ten levon uh and
alireza with nine and a half uh wesley
and mamadarov with nine uh and the
anxious to do that with nine and linear
dominguez with eight points in the
people who have not qualified anish
geary maxim bashar al-agrav gujarati
daniel naraditskiy lewang liam uh jordan
van forest uh eric hansen and wander
liang so we're gonna be covering the
main event as well and if you have any
of your favorite games from the
preliminaries also do check out uh do
use hashtag suggestion and i will go
through your uh
suggestion uh so yeah once again i hope
you guys enjoyed it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
very nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world uh thank
y'all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day